traditionnelle conférence de presse du
lundi quelques journalistes au tour de
fabien courtial entraîneur et manager
général de ça rend disponible ouvert une
nécessité pour le club une relativement
à l'aise et communiquer correctement
pour pour donner envie aux gens de venir
nous voir pour différentes choses
bien sûr c'est très très important de
communiquer aujourd'hui voilà que ce
soit aux verts le spectateur le
spectateur lambda ouvert le partenaire
ouvert l'institutionnel ou voilà ces
titres mondiaux pour le hand français le
championnat élite reste pourtant assez
confidentielle avec des budgets moindres
par rapport au foot petite partie
tranquille pendant de valeur
quoi tu vois la blessée à deux jours du
match bien préparer le match du mercredi
commence par bien connaître son
adversaire
tout est prévu à l'espace pour toi donc
là enfin si l'ondé ils ont chacun une
clé avec leur nom et je fais le montage
le montage vidéo de toulouse dessus je
vous montrais je vous montrer ce que ça
donne et donc il devait l'amener là donc
je pense qu'il va payer une petite
amende une amende pour remplir la caisse
des joueurs oublient routard passages
dans les médias tout se paie et se
dépense en fin de saison
en attendant l'heure est au travail on
va s'entraîner là ce matin avec max
bausch et mon préparateur physique
travail physique un petit peu sûr de la
vitesse explosivité parce qu'on a à deux
jours du match dans des petits ateliers
de renforcement et puis en parallèle moi
je vais travailler sur un but avec avec
des joueurs sur du travail et savoir
faire spécifique au poste
[Musique]
stephen king une matinée bien remplie
l'après midi ne sera pas plus tranquille
14 heures au bureau préparation de
l'entraînement spécifique ce que je vous
montrais je travaille à partir de de
séquençage vidéo de l'adversaire donc là
j'ai identifié par exemple un mouvement
qu'il faisait beaucoup et donc on va
essayer tout à l'heure de refaire ce
mouvement là avec mes joueurs pour que
les défenseurs sur essaye de d'anticiper
un petit peu et de voir comment on va
faire 16h retour à la salle avec une
nouvelle tête parmi les joueurs yohan
perrin vient d'arriver après une autre
journée de travail